[Music]
he walked right off that stage and
straight into the hearts and panties of
every girl in that high school that is a
video that started the water bottle flip
challenge revolution I think we do very
little research that's where you flip a
half-empty water bottle everyone lose
their minds when it lands perfectly it's
actually incredibly easy but thankfully
the Internet is made up of idiots
[Music]
[Applause]
you have any special towel
Maureen it's not a challenge if everyone
can do it I'm not trying to play the
game I'm trying to change it forever
[Music]
[Applause]
nailed it did I forget to put the cap on
I feel like I forgot to put the cap on
hi my name is Ryan and I tell everyone I
play football but I'm just the kicker hi
my name is Kaylee enough a bitch up my
name is Brian and I went long socks to
school so nobody can see my kid cool my
name's Anne I and I'm together with
black bitch at new city I think I'm just
get bitches cuz I lost weight my name is
John Dominic and my dad will sue you my
name is Cameron and I still have the air
enjoy my name's Addison and I swear I'm
the most popular girl at Newsome my name
is Charlie and I went I'm making sure
that the fashion statement
my name is there and I am the leader of
Isis and I wear ugly shirts that take
the focus off of my eyebrows everything
you Millennials do is god-awful
but then you come up with something like
this and totally redeem yourselves
challenge is where high school kids mock
their friends to their face and tack on
a condescending and since there's no
place more childish than this office
what better way for you to get to know
the people who work for me actually
candy I'm a guest
my husband some of those kids don't know
a step back from a fadeaway smdh that
was the step-back challenge oddly
popular I'm told basketball is a team
sport if you ask me a lot of hero ball
was being played in that urban school
I'd like to take this craze to one of
our many fine predominately white
Beverly Hills prep schools excuse me do
you enjoy the sport of basketball yeah
it's okay I guess
show me you're taking a charge
excuse me do you enjoy the sport of
basketball I like watching the playoffs
show me your intentional foul excuse me
to enjoy the sport at basketball yeah I
could take here leave it so we are two
in a bounce pass excuse me do you enjoy
the sport of basketball not really to be
honest surely you're sitting on the
bench to be doing the sport of
basketball
I prefer tennis show me your hustle rule
players are life
you